- [Narrator] The Trumps,
America's first family
and the first first
family in 150 years
without a first pet.
That is, until an adorable
American bulldog puppy
was found eating a taco
bowl from the dumpster
behind Trump Tower.
Now he's going from the
doghouse to the White House.
He's Donald Pup, the Trump Pup.
♪ Trump Pup chasing the gardener
♪ Trump Pup biting reporters
♪ Trump Pup going on Twitter
♪ Trump Pup deporting chihuahuas
♪ Trump Pup going
back on Twitter again
♪ Trump Pup humping
a Russian Wolfhound
♪ Trump Pup taking
time out for fun
♪ Trump Pup, come
on give him a chance
♪ What could go wrong
Trump Pup, Legend of
the Last First Dog.